[Music]
kylie jenner's daughter stormy steals
the show and looks like she might be
taking after her dad travis scott with
her beatboxing skills
yup like father like daughter
[Music]
caught the cute moment while she was
indulging in a quick snack and after the
mom of two gave a tour of her favorite
spaces in her kids rooms which included
this glimpse of stormy's designer shoe
and hat collection even better fans got
a glimpse of kylie's five-month-old son
soaking up some kylie baby products
[Music]
talk about too cute at least from what
we can see and stormy makes a brief
cameo too
[Music]
she's the cool one we agree last month
the source told e.t stormy is loving
being a big sister quote her and her
brother already share a very special
bond together she's so excited to be an
older sister and watch her baby brother
grow
i mean it's so much fun the family grows
and it's getting bigger all the time and
yeah it's really fun to see the babies
have babies
while we have yet to find out the name
of kylie and travis's baby boy the
beauty mogul told us back in april they
were narrowing things down we have some
um
we have some really strong options but
we haven't officially changed it we have
some placeholders so before i officially
change it i just want to be sure you're
seeing that little personality
of course kylie initially announced
their son's name was wolf but explained
to et why they never made it official i
liked the name i don't think anything i
still like this i love it i love it i
like wolf i just wasn't him we'll have
to wait and see what name stuck which
could be revealed on season two of the
kardashians we know kylie's pregnancy
and birth experience play a part thanks
to this just released trailer
i made a baby this is my 11th grandchild
in the meantime the reality star seems
to be focused on sharing adorable
moments of her eldest child even if it's
at her own expense
stormy got kylie good pranking her mom
with a silly face filter for her first
official video on her mom's account of
course we've been obsessed with all the
videos stormy creates with her mom are
you kidding me
stormy
you look like mommy baby
gotta say kylie better watch out for the
next big influencer because this little
girl is taking social media by storm or
better yet stormy
[Music]
you